[Musique]
c'est devenu une tradition le lundi
c'est le genre de la chronique sport
bonsoir amical et demi d'euros en 5
heures et c'est toujours un plaisir de
revenir ici c'est pour moi également
alors vous venez sur ce plateau pour
nous présenter les principaux résultats
sportifs du week-end dans le département
il y en a beaucoup et on commence par du
football américain
c'était la reprise pour les templiers
d'elancourt et ils ont dû s'employer ce
samedi soir pour remporter leur première
victoire de la saison dans le
championnat de 2e division
les footballeurs saint quentinois ont
réussi à battre les pionniers de
touraine à domicile dans le money time
dans les toutes dernières minutes
score final 14 à 13 en écoute les
réactions au micro de tv 78 la victoire
est toujours mérité on sait on s'est
battu pour pour aller la chercher
on était mené tout le match on est parti
le chercher sur le dernier drive et au
final on a juste marqué un peu plus que
les autres ce qu'il fallait faire
victoire méritée puisque toute façon du
port c'est bon à prendre
après la manière n'est pas forcément là
mais est il faut dire que les tant pis
se sont fait très peur grégory eux qui
espéraient passer une soirée tranquille
à la mi temps ils étaient menés à 6 à 0
sur l'interface et ses pionniers
pionniers de touraine les explications
avec le joueur david à pradelles premier
match de saison on connaît pas les
équipes en face on n'a pas eu le temps
de les voir voir ce qu'ils vont voir
leur l'or alors que l'e-book on n'a rien
vu de la saison donc forcément le temps
d'adaptation on a un jeune cube et donc
forcément il fallait qu'il prenne avec
lexmark les templiers devront trouver
leurs marques rapidement les
footballeurs se déplaceront sur le
terrain des diables rouges de villepinte
ce samedi 19 janvier l'équipe i prétan
également une montée en fin de saison et
après le football américain on passe un
autre sport de contact qui ressemble
aussi au foot eu à cesser leur grille
horaire on prend la direction versailles
rien n'arrête versailles les hommes de
la cité royale ont remporté une 10e
victoire consécutive ce dimanche 13
janvier leur victime du jour monter son
deuxième du classement les versets ils
ont emporté 16 à 5
mais cette fois ci sans panache une
réaction au micro de manon varaldo les
objectifs sont clairs c'est à dire que
nous on veut rien lâcher
on va essayer de gagner tous nos matches
comme on fait tous les week-ends le but
va être aussi docile intégré pas mal de
joueurs comme on l'a fait avec des
rotations pour tout le monde puisse
goûter la belle aventure est bien
évidemment on essaie d'aller le premier
impossible après avec cette victoire les
versailles et compte douze unités
d'avancé sur leur dauphin montesson
après dix journées disputées même si la
montée en fédérale 3 semble se dessiner
pour versailles on va voir la classe ont
justement grégory versailles 46 points à
montesson 34 points le staff veut
continuer à engranger des points et on a
pas on n'a pas lu l'interview
malheureusement michael mais c'est pas
grave on pourra peut-être la retrouver
dans votre set lui correctement ou en
tout cas pour continuer sa série
d'invincibilité versa il se rendra sur
le terrain de gif-sur-yvette le huitième
du classement ce dimanche 20 janvier je
note ce rendez vous car c'est à côté de
chez moi dans l'essonne mikel pour votre
7,8 sport quel est le programme quelle
est la suite du programme aura forcément
des templiers d'elancourt du rc
versailles qui a remporté également une
très belle victoire ce week-end et on
parlera de paris-nice la constituante
qui passera par les villes par les
yvelines un départ de
saint-germain-en-laye saint germain en
laye et deuxième étapes depuis les
bréviaires merci michael et le 7-8 sport
bien sûr c'est à retrouver juste après
ce journal